I couldn't believe it when he got to the
part about a republic if you can keep it
I'm like listen man I like Rhonda
Sanders as a politician he has great
policy he's doing a great job
but holy crap did they not give this guy
one minute of meeting training did they
not have any kind of of campaign coach
be like go watch Captain America one
time
and just watch watch any Hollywood movie
where the protagonist gives a speech
about saving the world just just that in
fact watch SNL as they mock that look
man
the Santa's people are probably gonna
get mad because they like him but I'm
not pulling punches I like Elon I like
DeSantis but that had negative Charisma
negative I agree I look I I like
DeSantis a lot I think everything he was
saying there was spot on every single
word but I'll be honest I was I was
literally bored to tears I mean it's
remarkable to me that someone who said
so many things that were so true that
would have gotten a standing ovation
from any group of conservatives who are
outside of the establishment where they
just delivered with a little bit more
energy